será más un deporte es la literatura que
quiere ser real de qué estamos hablando
ahora hablamos del crisis el deporte que
emocionaba en la saga de harry potter
una disciplina que en nuestro mundo
tiene sus orígenes en eeuu a comienzos
del siglo y ya está presente en unos 40
países obviamente adaptado para nosotros
los magos los que no tenemos margen no
podemos volar sobre las escobas este fin
de semana se celebró ese celebró en
angers la copa de francia de quidditch
en el país galo se estima que hay unas
12 unos dos equipos activos de este
deporte como vemos aquí no se utiliza
una escoba sino un palo los jugadores
los llevan y aquellos que lo practican
dicen que aporta un grado de dificultad
el objetivo es conseguir que la quaffle
que es una pelota un poco más pequeña
que una de voleibol pase por los aros
del rival luchando contra los
golpeadores que a su vez portan las
bloggers que son las pelotas con
capacidad de noquear al rival y no falta
tampoco la apreciada snitch las miradas
la que vemos ahí es esa pelota dorada
que da la victoria a su captor sobre el
terreno es una persona quien lleva las
yendo de los buscadores que buscan los
seguidores del cliché ser un deporte al
completo
es nuestro objetivo como federación que
somos demostrar que somos de verdad un
deporte serio que organiza competiciones
como cualquier otro deporte
y ponemos la misma intensidad la misma
pasión que cualquier otro deporte
individual o colectivo
seguramente vemos canchas de cliché en
algunos años o por todo el mundo juan
gracias como siempre por todos